Where a little fucking high ride.
We're going to get through it.
I'm so bummed.
I was thinking about going to Hawaii the other day and then his fucking,
you know happened.
I'm like,
of all the times I was there I,
oh you were there when it happened.
It was in Lanai.
I was on one of the other islands.
Did you feel the earthquake?
No,
I didn't feel it.
It's,
you know,
it's separated by quite a lot is a lot of water and the way the big earthquake
happened actually after the plane took off,
so we were in the air when the big one hit.
Oh yeah.
Which it's apparently a big one.
Like a five nine I think was even more than that.
Was it six Oh,
oh right.
They had a big one and then they had a fucking really big one.
I'm five nine it's big.
I think the way it works,
I'm sure someone will correct me here.
I think the way it works is a five six is like really powerful,
but a five,
seven is twice as powerful than a five.
Eight is twice as powerful as that.
So when you get up to seven,
like that's some world changing shit.
It's actually 6.9 my God.
That's insane.
Oh my God.
Can you imagine being on the God?
Who was that powerful?
That's so big.
That's such a big earthquake,
man.
Did you see the um,
I put it up.
It's so funny,
Dude.
You put up anything that's from CNN and people wanted to put her up from a
verifiable source.
Not Cnn.
CNN.
It's bullshit.
It's a video.
You fucking asshole.
It's a video of lava eating a car.
My stake,
CNN faked it.
Blessed.
But I'd like to say I like the secret closest fab diets at CNN.
It's not full of shit.
And then I'll go to their website.
Stupid to people are so goofy.
They're so goofy with this fake new shit.
It's lava.
It ate a car.
It happened.
Do you see the video?
Yeah,
the white,
the white car pull this shit up.
I think it's called that.
That cards forever going to be in rock.
So like when we all died and like the future,
like people can like find this card and the wheels.
It's broken down to the bare elements at this point.
I'm assuming it just got completely melted.
I wonder.
They say that stuff is 2000 degrees and it's so hot,
but it's molten rock.
So like if it didn't burn through your feet or I give you,
if you weren't flammable at all for some strange reason,
you could actually walk on it.
Yeah.
And I'm like what?
I thought you would just sink in it but no,
and apparently it's cooling like right out of after it gets out of the surface.
Oh this is so crazy.
This is like a monster.
So we're watching this lava flow on Hawaii's big island.
I like how Jamie went with CBS news flipped sooner.
Brew folk the Food News.
Actually Brandon Clement got the video.
Oh powerful.
Brendan Clement.
But this guy,
whoever he is a bad motherfucker cause look what he was next to.
He was filming this.
I mean he was near this thing.
Oh my God.
Like,
imagine being on that street and staying,
what kind of a crazy fuck you have to be to be on that street and stay.
And then it's 6.9 hits during all this.
That's so big.
That's such a crazy earthquake.
But they live on a volcano.
I mean,
it's one of the reasons why a lot of people don't want to live on the big
island.
So shit like this.
Yeah,
that splatter one's crazy.
There's a fissure in this neighborhood.
There's a subdivision out there and it's something is states,
I forget what it is,
but they're fucking neighborhood.
Do the,
the,
the ground opened up in their neighborhood.
I mean,
if you lived,
you know,
thousands of years ago,
this would be an angry God coming to attack your village.
Could you imagine if normal days you're in Hawaii,
you're in one of the most beautiful places on the planet.
You're just chilling and the sun is perfect.
And you'd see in the ocean,
you hear the seagulls and you see dolphins and shit,
and then the ground opens up and hell starts pouring out,
eats your house each,
your Mustang fuck.
And they were talking about it today on the news of like,
there's nothing we can do is nothing that I can't pour water on it.
Nope,
can't do shit.
You're not going to stop it.
It's too big.